oh yeah I'm sorry that is a bit of a
late start of this but we have the first
didn't miss much
playing zucchini 81 again I hit the
wrong button there yeah and now the the
recording has actually started so we
have a modern main line Petrov and now
White has a very wide choice between
moves but sorry yeah this is not really
that great
no white cannot take on f7 maybe I don't
think it did you with this directly but
it is close to that you should go back
to a3 which renders the whole thing kind
of pointless I also have 95 that is also
fine but h6 is a little bit a little bit
more direct
tonight they have seven look ma this is
trapped he can go 25 but I have bishop
g6 always loved it yeah you play it like
I played instantly I mean I know what
I'm doing and he just didn't just
doesn't believe me
yeah anyway so Queen d5 is the only way
to really okay okay I'm a little bit
stunned I mean that looks completely
wrong so just here I guess okay
night if I why do we just castle first
I don't know yeah yeah I'm always feel
nervous if I'm not castling so let's do
it
[Music]
tonight five in this position it should
be good yeah we're taking here and I
have Queenie six potentially with the
tempo okay he goes to be three so we
should be six it's a simple plain flame
night f7 should win this pawn so I just
get to take the pawn right or 24 at the
end oh man the end it's got Queen D for
our great miracle defenseless young and
now I'm blundering a piece come on
you're playing this complete crap and
then I'm blundering a piece yeah
fantastic
okay and it's frustrating
I mean Knight takes f7 and night xh6
it's just atrocious ly bad I mean this
is just complete crap you know and it's
super obvious crap okay okay so Bishop
e6 is even stronger okay well this is
just clearly better for black anyway why
don't you sacrifice a piece there you
just have to go back to f3 and it's so
normal game yeah and this is like
completely clearly bred for white but
okay I'm wandering the house so you can
play any kind of nonsense am oh man so
yeah C 585 okay I mean this move is also
of course better for black but I mean
okay I don't pay it I never play Knight
f7 if I see beforehand that I wanted to
take on h4 of course and but the problem
is that he has this move which is a
double attack that is the miracle
defense that works here otherwise white
would just lose anyway
so this is why nine f7 is bad I can just
play something like that
and I mean this is more or less winning
from like those pawns go nowhere and I
will just win them step by step I mean
the engine is kind of conservative with
the minus 0.9 but yeah I mean it's just
like very obviously terrible to play
this here so okay anyway if you play b6
yeah you shouldn't complain
so yeah anything wrong anything really
are not b6 I can actually take aged form
because of rookie aid but that is now
probably what I needed to do because I
mean this is annoying that I have to
care about is a seven but okay if I see
that there is a tricky with two Caribs
Kuna for I just played this and I'm just
clearly better and this is just
they are completely completed you see
blundering blundering the peace Queenie
aids you can actually still play what
grey okay let's to him I mean white is
now better after this move but at least
you know what always annoys me and said
you know I played this a temple and I'm
not blundering this and he still takes
it and it's totally obvious that this is
crap and he's like 2500 Hamlet so what
is that what is that yeah yeah okay
anyway again if you play b6 you cannot
complain so c5 is probably even stronger
here yeah I didn't quite want to play
this
where it is strong it's probably
stronger the main problem is that this
is a bad sacrifice because those pawns
are far behind and they don't move quite
clearly never F poor never moves gee
poor never moves this is a problem yeah
and here just here you just are clearly
Belarus what it is here after age six
you just have to go back it's what you
have to do okay anyway thanks for
watching